[Música]
a periferia preparar pessoas para
alcançar todos os espaços espaços eles
econômicos culturais acadêmicos até o
mundo corporativo
mas quando a gente é periférico a gente
nem sempre acredito que a gente pode
chegar ali naquele espaço
eu comecei a entender que a gente pode
trazer tudo que a gente aprendeu na
periferia
durante a nossa jornada e quando a gente
chega ali naqueles espaços mas pa trazer
como eu consegui entender isso
transmitir como essas traduções podem
ser feitas essas conexões podem ser
feitas
eu preciso falar um pouquinho sobre
minha vivência sobre a minha história e
para falar sobre a vivência minha
história eu preciso falar sobre a
periferia de taboão da serra em são
paulo e é pra lá que eu quero levar
vocês eu crescer no taboão da serra
escutando rapidez de cedo já que a minha
mãe gostava de rap e eu falo sobre rap
porque o rap foi o que fez eu criar
curiosidades
eu descobri as escolhas que eu tinha e
fazer essas escolhas que muitas vezes
era entre ficar calada ou parada e
outras me expressar falar e movimentar o
que fazer crescer além do rap ter sido
uma parte importante na minha vida
principalmente quando eu entrei em
espaços não periféricos porque o rapper
fez o me conectar comigo mesma e eu
entender quem era eu voltar para camila
do taboão da serra
eu comecei a psico lar por diversas
periferias e circulando por diversas
periferias por vários motivos
né o principal deles era porque era isso
que eu conhecia era isso que me deixava
confortável eram essas pessoas que eu
fui criado e que me deixavam confortável
mas era muito por conta dos projetos que
participar
fã do meu amor por música por rap às
vezes simplesmente porque eu queria sair
do da zona sul de são paulo e para a
zona leste de são paulo
e ali eu comecei a conhecer pessoas
diferentes e comecei a perceber tudo que
a gente faz na periferia
comecei a perceber o quanto que a gente
cria eu comecei a perceber e conhecer
pessoas que estavam ali produzindo
música estudando música tocando
instrumentos falando sobre tecnologia
inovando aprender outras línguas tudo
ali na periferia
tudo sem recurso somente dividindo
pesquisando aprendendo em conjunto sem
nenhum recurso e fazendo a opção que é o
que mais a gente tem na preferia a gente
tem essa opção conhecimento e
criatividade
pensando sobre tudo aquilo que eu via eu
comecei a me questionar
eu comecei a questionar sobre como que
sem recursos a gente conseguia fazer
tudo isso e como seria se a gente
tivesse recurso a gente tivesse tudo bem
não recursos mas a chance de errar
o periférico é preferir não tem essa
chance e eu acredito que por conta disso
que às vezes a gente quer escapar da
periferia que a gente quer fugir daquele
lugar ea gente acaba internalizando como
se aquilo fosse uma coisa ruim como se
aquele lugar
foi horrível como se todas as pessoas
dali fossem hoje vez em quando a gente
faz isso a gente acaba fechando no nível
porque a gente é da ale e muitas vezes a
gente traz essa visão essa essa idéia de
preferia que é uma ideia que nem sempre
está ligada na realidade nem sempre
qualidade da nossa vivência periférica
muitas vezes está conectada com a
opinião de uma parte da sociedade que
não faz idéia do que é ser periférico e
a gente coloca isso como sempre o nosso
a gente esquece
parece que a periferia tem opção tem
criatividade tem conhecimento tem sonhos
eu cresci carregando um desses sonhos
quero sonho da minha família de me ver
em uma universidade e formada
eu vou trazer um exemplo pra vocês e o
que é entrar na universidade se formar
pra gente como que isso se conecta com a
gente
o porquê disso e eu acredito que quem é
periférico provavelmente teve uma dessas
falas dentro de casa alguém na sua casa
deve ter falado alguma vez para vocês
sobre isso seja sua mãe e sua tia sua
avó a quem falou que é você precisa
estudar para ser alguém na vida e você
precisa pagar todas as suas contas
aí tem o direitista pra você ter o seu
nome limpo porque a única coisa que a
gente tem o nosso nome o que faz sentido
quando a gente está ali mas quando você
começa a se desconstruir quando como
você começa a se entender
você começa a perceber que você já é
alguém que você tem muito mais do que o
seu nome por conta do sonho que eu tive
e que eu estava carregando na minha
família de entrar na universidade
eu acabei entrando em um cursinho sem
saber exatamente o que eu queria
sem ter a mínima idéia porque não tinha
referência nenhuma universidade
diferença nenhuma dentro da minha casa e
principalmente porque quando a gente
fala sobre futuro quando a gente tem
essas conversas dessas conversas elas
não se expandem por que a gente não tem
tanta referência a gente não tem
referência do que entrar numa
universidade quaid como que a gente
escolhe como são feitas as escolhas qual
que vai ser o desenvolvimento o
desenvolvimento de carreira planejamento
de carreira que isso a gente acaba não
tendo essa ideia mas eu entrei no
cursinho de qualquer jeito
ali naquele cursinho que tinham pessoas
como eu prefere casas sem dinheiro e
tentam se encontrar também a gente
acabou se juntando e aí a gente vem de
algumas coisas e fazer um dinheiro que a
gente pagava o próprio cursinho ea gente
às vezes sobre alguma coisa então a
gente pagava a nossa passagem de volta
ali se for pensar se a gente for parar
pra pensar você consegue já entender e
já consegue perceber várias habilidades
só que a gente não tinha idéia a gente
não sabia que a gente tava inovando que
a gente estava empreendendo a gente não
colocava esse nome
tudo bem eu fiquei nesse curso em um ano
fiz as minhas escolhas aleatórias de
universidades e cursos
prestei para as universidades e não
passei não passar na universidade
ao mesmo tempo foi triste e
decepcionante mas foi o momento que fez
com que eu percebesse que tinha outras
possibilidades que eu tinha a
possibilidade de ter outros sonhos
isso aconteceu num dia específico em um
momento específico no qual eu atravessei
a rua durante a minha pausa do trabalho
e eu trabalhava como operadora de
telemarketing
essa é a cara de quem trabalha de
operadora de telemarketing e tinham duas
opções pra a comprar uma coisa para
comer nenhuma dessas opções eram as
opções que eu fazia porque a gente
sempre é pra coxinha
eu fui então hoje eu vou fazer alguma
coisa diferente eu quero nesse lugar
eu entrei no lugar lógico no meu
desconforto óbvio e comecei a prestar
atenção no que estava acontecendo ao meu
redor que isso significa que estava
prestando atenção na conversa de alguém
e aos 25 anos 24 anos na verdade eu
descobri uma coisa chamada intercâmbio
que pra minha realidade era impossível
tinha uma distância incrível entre essa
ideia ea periferia
eu lembro que a sensação que eu tinha
era nossa o qual para aí as pessoas saem
do brasil para estudar não fazer muito
sentido pra mim eu não fazia idéia do
que era aquilo era um surreal assim só
que aí começou a despertar coisas em mim
eu comecei a colocar
rio como objetivo e como sonho e comecei
a pesquisar comecei a entender como
funcionava comecei a me preparar e eu
pensei o vôo
agora vou entrar nesse clube nossa nossa
agora vai ser agora vou sair da
periferia agora vou sair do tabuão
agora nossa ninguém me segura estourei
moleque e não deu certo
não deu certo porque porque eu estava
tentando enquadrar eu queria fugir
e quando falo que eu queria fugir não
era porque eu tinha vergonha dali mas eu
também assumo também tinha orgulho eu
queria algo mais
eu queria tudo que eu poderia eu queria
fazer isso que as pessoas estavam
fazendo
foi muito porque eu não sabia as regras
não sabe o jogo
e essas regras são regras que
normalmente elas são criadas baseadas em
referências de pessoas que são
totalmente distantes do que é ser negro
periférico e você também comecem a
acreditar que você pode só entrar ali se
você anulá esquecer quem você é
então eu peguei tudo que era mais taboão
da serra que eu tinha e joguei
e é isso fez com que eu não levo não
entregar seu melhor não mostrasse quem
eu era
não não consegue não conseguiu se
desenvolver o thalia ou trazer a camila
até que não é nenhuma questão de
inteligência sabe é uma questão de se
sentir confortável com quem você é e eu
não me sentia naquele momento mas aí
começou a passar o tempo algumas coisas
aconteceram na minha vida eu comecei a
perceber que a gente pode ser várias
coisas e ser periféricos
essa foto é um exemplo disso é só falta
uma foto dentro de uma das maiores
empresas de tecnologia do mundo no qual
eu consegui circular e traduzir e
conectar tudo que eu via minha vida
inteira
dentro da preferia como no corporativo
ali ao mesmo tempo que eu estava de
salto e eu tava falando sobre tecnologia
ou fazendo qualquer outra coisa que
tinha a ver com a minha função eu
conseguia me conectar com a periferia e
pensar na periferia traz é a periferia
praquele lugar e o que fez chegar até
ali foi tudo que ouvi na preferia todas
as conexões todas as vivências que eu
tive eu acredito que a sociedade ela
consegue sim ver o magnífico em todos os
lugares mas todos os lugares que remetem
a referência que eles têm de magníficos
e brilhante e eu vou repetir novamente
que essas diferenças não são negras ou
periféricas e quando tem uma um
brilhante um magnífico na periferia elas
não reconhecem e não aceitam ea gente é
magnífico
a gente traz muita vivência a gente traz
muita coisa ea gente pode fazer tudo
isso
nesses espaços então a gente pode ser
periférico e acadêmico verifica que o
executivo prefere fazer intercâmbio o
que a gente quiser fazer o melhor dos
dois e arrasar nos dois e eu comecei a
entender ali um pouco sobre isso começa
a entender ali sobre como que ter
passado depois de três nãos
eu recebi três nãos no quarto eu recebi
uns e na quarta tentativa recebe 15 e
que essa quarta tentativa e esse sim só
foi possível porque eu era filha de uma
empregada doméstica com um motoboy que
circulou a adolescência dela inteira
entre periferias e aprendeu tudo o que
ela tinha aprendido até então até hoje
até aos 35 anos
lá no taboão da serra
e aí o hoje eu falo que eu sou o fruto
disso e o que me levou pra ir pra esse
lugar
me levou a fazer esse intercâmbio hoje
ser uma mulher que trabalhou em uma das
maiores empresas do mundo
já vi viajou e para mais de nove países
já fez fez a sua faculdade essa
universidade mas não parou só lhe fez
mais alcançou mais foi a periferia foi
essas vivências foram essas vivências
que fizeram eu sei quem eu sou isso a
minha construção está a ser camila o
taboão é ser eu
eu assumo que não foi fácil
foi muito doloroso e aí que eu usava pra
me ajudar
o rep sim eu entrava no estacionamento
de um dos endereços mais importantes de
são paulo e uma das empresas de
tecnologia mais importantes do mundo
escutando jesus chorou com rádio
trincando não racionais mcs porque era
assim que eu começava o meu dia e
terminava o meu dia sem medo ou sem
seguranças e com isso também aprendi que
a gente tem coisas na preferia que o
mundo corporativo busca nos talentos
fora nos talentos profissionais que são
o soft skills
só que na preferia a gente chama de soft
skills a gente chama de e corre ou a
forma com que a gente faz o nosso corre
e é tudo uma questão de tradução por
exemplo sagacidade a gente consegue
traduzir a estratégia porque que é uma
estratégia é pensar e coordenar ações
se você pegar todas as idades que você
tem o que essa da cidade
você vai conseguir chegar até ali até
que ele meio não periférico e
provavelmente vai conseguir chegar até o
mundo corporativo e vai ver que tudo que
você faz se você traduzir você tá sendo
estratégico é só gente mudar nossa chave
é só gente traduzir aquilo aquelas
nossas vivências ou os projetos que a
gente faz dentro da preferia os
coletivos que a gente cria tudo isso a
liderança tudo isso é trabalho em equipe
o meu pai teve
de do alho na feira ter reinventado como
ele é vender ali na feira ou qualquer
outra forma que a minha família e várias
outras famílias tentaram encontrar pra
trazer o sustento para sua casa e sua
inovação está empreendedorismo isso é
achar soluções diferentes e novas para
problemas antigos
ali eu comecei a entender tudo isso tudo
isso mas eu não tô aqui pra falar sobre
a minha história eu não tô aqui pra
falar sobre meritocracia
longe disso e eu não tô aqui pra falar
ou justificar as injustiças que existe
no brasil e no mundo
eu tô aqui pra falar sobre a
ressignificação da periferia
tanto da parte da gente periférico
quanto da parte das pessoas que não são
periféricas e por isso que eu peço pra
vocês saírem daqui com uma missão de se
conectar com pessoas que vivem em
espaços sociais de frente de vocês
e quando falo conectar e entender
conexão para genish é diferente
a conexão é via de mão dupla é também
vocês pegarem o privilégio ou a
oportunidade que vocês têm e da voz pra
gente pra gente contar nossa história e
também entender que a gente não quer só
saber regra do jogo a gente quer
participar
a gente quer fechar com vocês aqui a
gente quer fazer a gente quer fazer em
conjunto a gente quer fortalecer ea
gente pode se fortalecer e eu falo para
vocês perceberem também que a gente tem
potencialidade que a gente pode impactar
sua vida e pode trazer coisas incríveis
não só para a sua vida mas para a sua
organização da sua instituição
mas eu não tô falando pra você vem com
um olhar filantrópico é pra mim com um
olhar de oportunidade oportunidade real
verdadeira porque assim eu consigo
trazer o meu melhor
a minha potencialidade e você consegue
encher
essa potencialidade que tem em mim pra
quem é periférico com o recado que eu
tenho é bom olhar para a gente vamos
perceber o quanto que a gente é potência
vamos perceber que a gente queria que a
gente nova que a gente traz discutir a
opção que a gente lidera há muito tempo
só que ninguém falou pra gente e que a
gente é o que os nossos pais ea nossa
comunidade nos criou para ser potência
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]